[Music]
all right welcome to GD 50 lecture 5
today's topic is the Legend of Zelda as
you can see on the screen there very
iconic game last week we did Super Mario
Brothers which is arguably the most
iconic video game of all time Legend of
Zelda is a close contender even now just
like with Mario they're producing very
wonderful games I think last year breath
of the wild took all the I forget which
ceremony it was or award sort of show
but it took like every award possible
this last year at the latest Elder
breadth of the wild so it feels sort of
apropos to talk about Legend of Zelda in
that context as well here's a screenshot
of the original Legend of Zelda it was
an NES title just like Super Mario
Brothers a you know just like most games
of its time tile-based you can sort of
see how the surroundings are sort of
layered tiles bit by bit well the goal
of the game overall was to sort of
explore this open world which is kind of
a first of its kind in controlled link
shown at the very bottom there you had a
sword you had bombs you had arrows red
you went to go find rubies you went
through dungeons you laid monsters and
bosses and then ultimately the goal was
to obtain the Triforce which is shown at
the very top left and right of the slide
here here's a screenshot another
screenshot legends is all the inside an
actual dungeon where you can see at the
very top there's got like a map layout
maps are sort of arranged in a grid and
you could go in a room by room whereby
each room was the entire width of the in
height of the screen looking for you
know solving puzzles looking for items
that sort of thing you can see there
it's a monster there you have hearts at
the very top right so when you take
damage hearts sort of decrement we'll
see both of these the hearts and the the
dungeon aspect of the game today in
lecture as well as you know the the
width and height of the room being a a
dungeon tile and controlling an avatar
but this is sort of a representative
screenshot of what the game looked like
back in the day some topics today that
we'll be discussing in order to
implement through the foundation for
what a game engine like this might look
like are things like top-down
perspective so as you can see in this
screenshot we're looking at you know
link from the very top and a bird's-eye
view as opposed to how we used to look
at Mario from the side where it was sort
of like a side scroller
here we're actually looking at things
from the top down so we have a view of
the room in a sort of a different
perspective there's sort of a there's
not really a Z access technically
speaking but there sort of is you can
implement things like gravity in a game
engine like this by jumping over holes
and things like that but there's no
gravity like there was in a Super Mario
where you know you walked left-to-right
you jump over gaps and it's very easy to
see in that sort of sense well be
talking about infinite dungeon
generation so in the context of today's
example we'll see how we can go about
implementing a dungeon that sort of you
can go through forever and ever and how
to sort of model that and make it look
as if you're traveling through a dungeon
over and over again and going through
different screens and different rooms
that are all different but in reality
we'll see it's actually just an illusion
like we've seen before in Prior lectures
we'll talk about hitboxes and hurt boxes
and what the difference is between the
two hit boxes being rectangles on the
screen that inflict damage upon other
entities in your game world and hurt
boxes sort of being the rectangle that
models where your player or whether
where an entity in the game can be hurt
by other hit boxes we'll look at events
so events are a way of sort of
broadcasting some key or some message
that tells the game world oh this thing
happened and let me register a function
to call when that sort of event is
processed so on some event you know
dispatch an event and then upon that
event being received by whatever's
listening for it perform this chunk of
code it allows you to sort of decouple
aspects of your game engine a little bit
and makes for a little bit more readable
code and allows you to do some
interesting things with like
achievements for example where you don't
necessarily want to pull every single
frame oh did I do this sort of arbitrary
list of things this frame rather you can
just process all of that within the
event and have a listener and a function
that you know every time you broadcast
Oh pick up coin maybe I have an
achievement that's like oh how I picked
up 50 coins in this level you know your
achievement callback function in your
event cannon can then look for that and
in your game loop you don't have to say
every frame oh if player has 850 coins
and you sort of take out blow - that
would exist in your sort of overall game
loop that way and we'll see an example
of how we use that in today's lecture
we'll look at screen scrolling so a very
common are very sort of iconic aspect of
Legend of Zelda is when you're going
from one screen to another there's a
sort of transition period as one screen
loads and the other screen goes away in
hardware in the NES but this was sort of
the only way you could actually render a
lot of sort of more than a screen width
of tiles you actually had to dynamically
load in tiles and sort of overwrite
tiles that existed before that in memory
but today we'll see how we can sort of
create the illusion of doing that by
just drawing a room and then having our
main room and then just sort of tweening
over and then setting everything back to
the origin at 0 0 and it makes it look
as if we're moving you know back and
forth between all these rooms when in
reality all we're doing is just doing a
shift and then putting everything back
to 0 0 so I'll sort of illustrate that
on the screen if I can and one of the
last things we'll look at his
data-driven design in the context of a
lot of types of games particularly RPGs
and action games it's often very
valuable to be able to model all of your
items entities sort of abilities
anything you really can as data rather
than logic in order to make it easier
for you to write one and two for you to
sort of allocate the design aspect of
your game to other people not just
programmers and have an engine that's
very versatile and moddable and we'll
take a look at how we implement sort of
a foundation for that later on but first
I'd like to illustrate a demo for
today's lecture a sort of implementation
of Legend of Zelda is there anybody that
would like to come up and sort of demo
this today in class awesome thank you so
much
so whenever you're ready just go ahead
and press the return key there and so we
see on the screen legend of 50 which is
our Legend of Zelda maka uh you know
ripoff sort of so if you press Enter you
go into this is the play state of the
game so you control an avatar you can
walk around you can interact with
switches as we saw here when you press
as a switch the doors open and once the
doors are open you can walk through them
and it does as well loop to before it it
transitions the screen a one entire
screen with height or width depending on
the direction up above and below we see
here now we're pressing spacebar to
actually swing our sword it's destroying
the entities in the game space so
there's a hit box triggering when you
press the spacebar that collides with
other entities in the game world if that
hit box hits there hurt box then they
are flagged as dead and they disappear
from the game world and so this goes on
ad infinitum it's just an infinite
dungeon so we he can go in between as
many forces as we want to all we're
doing is every time we go through throw
away spawn a new room delete the old one
and just keep going forever and ever and
ever in a game like Legend of Zelda it
typically doesn't work like this there's
a hard set number of rooms and they all
exist in sort of a 2d array and when you
generate your dungeon you sort of have
to take NIT consideration things like
where do I put the keys where do I put
the boss where I put treasure that sort
of thing we won't get too in-depth as to
how we can implement a complex algorithm
like that but we'll touch upon it a
little bit and talk about maybe some
ideas that we have and then it lastly if
we just if we want to demo as we can see
at the top left we have hearts there
which is iconic sort of Zelda and when
we do take damage from an enemy notice
that we flicker a little bit so there's
some rendering behavior triggering and
we become invulnerable when we take
damage and then lastly when we finally
take the last hit we get a little game
over screen using the Zelda font and
that's the game in a nutshell then we
can press ENTER and loop back so pretty
simple altogether but there's a lot of
pieces here that we haven't really seen
before so thank you very much for coming
up to
the game alright so that was a demo of
you know legend of 50 Legend of Zelda it
has a lot of the pieces that Zelda has
it's not as fully fleshed out of course
as a full game like Zelda which would be
monstrously large and there's a lot of
things we need to factor in
but the foundation is there we have the
dungeon foundation upon which we can
build a an actual generator if we wanted
to we have entities we have hit boxes we
could easily model because we have
switches in the game we could model
things like treasure chests that open
that have different states just like the
switch had different states and have
different objects in our game space
interact with other objects we have a
lot here and we'll talk about all of it
today so here's a few screenshots just
to show you know what we just looked at
our goal mainly is the second screenshot
on the top right which is the play state
that has all of the little pieces we
just saw but just to tie it all together
we do have a start state here and a game
over state which is relevant in regard
to the hearts on the top left so the
first thing that I'll talk about as we
sort of get the engine built up is where
do we go for getting our assets into the
game and just like in before prior
lectures prior to today we just have a
sprite sheet like we did with Mario
where everything is laid out in a fairly
even sequence of tile segments in this
case the segments are 16 by 16 pixels
here I've overlaid a grid just to show
that the picture is indeed perfectly 16
by 16 and this is something that you
should take into consideration and
consciously do when you're building your
game assets make it easy to chop up into
little pieces so you can then index into
this sprite via some table of quads and
then assign an ID to whatever object or
tile you want to rent it to the screen
and so we see if you look here things
like the doors they're not perfectly
modeled by one tile and so when you do
have things that are larger than 16 by
16 it's not quite as easy as oh you know
have an entity or an object with this
frame ID and draw it to the screen you
actually do a little bit more
complicated render logic so just offhand
if I wanted to draw a door does anybody
have any suggestions as to how I would
model that and/or draw it to the screen
so if we have a door that's not
perfectly a 16 or a you know a 16 by 16
pixel tile offhand the the you know what
we need to do is just basically store
all four of those tiles in this case or
at least you know keep track of however
many tiles your object is and then just
draw them based on some offset have the
you know an XY that represents the top
left of that object place it on the
right position and instead of drawing
just one tile we draw four tiles and
then instead of having just one
collision box that's 16 by 16 tiles you
can do a couple things you can either
check collision on all four of these
tiles or all at least all two of these
door tiles or model your own custom
hitbox that then maybe that object that
represents a doorway has control of so
you can say you know doorway collides
player and then the doorway has a height
and width of however many pixels it is
wide by tall here just this door part
and then you know you are able to then
build upon not just having one tile that
models an object or entity in your game
space but now you have more artistic
flexibility you can do things like have
doorways that are more than one pixel
wide and sort of have a more convincing
game world as a result of that and
you'll see a lot of things like that in
games like RPGs where you have full
houses that are obviously not just one
tile because that would be I mean
something you can model things as one
tile if you want to but from an artistic
perspective and from just a game engine
perspective it's a little bit easier to
programmatically be able to cut up all
your assets into tiles and draw them as
such so being able to sort of build upon
this the just the single sprite and be
able to do multiple sprites to represent
an object is the key to things like
houses things like big trees things that
are just more complicated than single
tiles as we see here the character
sprite sheet is as you can see a little
bit more complicated so this is an
example of a sprite sheet that has
padding sometimes you will get sprite
sheets that aren't neatly divided into
even segments and for a good reason
because
times you have tiles that are not
perfectly the width and height of
whatever your game engine styles are in
this case the player is actually 20
pixels tall and 16 pixels wide and on
top of that he's got different frames of
animation we can see here at the bottom
left he's got a sword swing animation
the sword swing animation is actually
stored in a 32 by 32 pixels frame
because sometimes depending on which
angle he's looking at his sprite can get
a little larger or smaller so when you
have a sprite with padding what's sort
of a way that we can draw this to the
screen reliably like how do we how do we
take this into consideration how would
we render a screen sprite with padding
so let's say this right here our
character swinging a sword is in a 32 by
32 pixel box right this sort of box
around here this white space but he's
only still maybe 16 pixels wide by 20
pixels tall or maybe he's some amount
similar to that in order to draw him to
the screen which you can look at in the
code all we really need to do is assign
that sprite and offset just say okay the
sprites offset X and offset Y are some
value that basically lets us draw the
sprite to a negative x and a negative Y
value and that'll shift the sprite up
such that it aligns perfectly with
wherever his X Y are and we can you can
take a look at that in the code to see
exactly how that works
lastly the actual entities for our game
world are different creatures and this
is a sprite sheet this is a more ideal
sprite sheet where everything is 16 by
16 pixels wide and tall and all we
really did here was justify the sprite
sheet using the regular utility function
generate quads by 16 16 we don't have to
worry about separate you know widths and
Heights for everything and we can create
animations very simply because of this
as a side note something that I like to
do when I'm you know parsing or when I'm
piecing apart a sprite sheet that's got
a lot of individual frames per tick with
them creating animations or I just need
to know it for a tile a particular tile
to draw to the screen it's kind of a
pain to manually look through each and
every tile one by one and say okay this
is one but okay if I want to find out
which one this the slime is I got a
count okay how many pixels wide is this
okay and then
by x force is 12 and then it's on the
fifth row so twelve times four plus one
will get me okay so it's at it's at
index 49 so I've spent you know a
non-trivial amount of time sort of hand
calculating what all these do I wrote a
simple Python script that will just go
over a file and just add a digit to each
individual quad to just show you at a
glance what each sprite is and this is
included in the distro so you can see
what it looks like
saves a lot of time and I recommend
trying when you're you know sort of
working with assets and you find
yourself doing something that takes a
long time and it sort of tedious and
mechanical maybe try to try to find a
way to sort of automate that or at least
make it easier to do things at a glance
in this case just simply imposing a
numerical grid solves that problem I
don't have to spend a significant amount
of time figuring out which frames of
animation the ghost facing left is I
know instantly it's 67 68 and 69 and
allows me to just crank things up that
much faster so the first thing we'll
take a look at is a sort of top-down
perspective and we mostly talked about
this before earlier but all it really is
is a tile map which we've seen before
the only difference is now instead of
looking at things from the side we're
just looking at things from up above so
what's it what's a probably the most
obvious consideration when designing a
top-down perspective versus a sort of
side-scrolling point of view being at
looking at particularly at how the tiles
are drawn what stands out
so the thing that stands out to me is
that we have things like shadows on
walls here we have also corners and
things altogether are skewed such that
they are almost like rotated slightly as
if they are simulating an angle of
rotation relative to the camera facing
from up above you can see this unlike
the player for example is sort of looks
or looks like you're looking at him from
kind of backwards and up when you're
modeling your assets that way you this
it's more convincing and Zelda has
always done this to make your assets
look as if they are slightly tilted and
that you're looking up above so when
you're designing a top-down game just
for convincing the sake of being more
convincing try and emulate that the
entities here like the skeleton and such
are a little bit more straight on the
bats and slimes and whatnot even though
they still have a little bit of that
appearance like the spider it sort of
looks as if it's from the top back but
modeling your assets from a top-down
perspective really that's mainly mainly
the thing pay attention to shadows and
highlights which adds a lot in terms of
convincing us that we're in this room
with lighting and also make sure that
you're doing things like corners and
stuff and making it look as if things
are slightly skewed rotation wise the
first thing that we're going to look at
in terms of the code and the distro is
Dungeon generation so in Legend of Zelda
dungeons are fixed they are completely
set in advance by the designers and in
most games this is actually the case in
our example and in a couple of other
examples a primary example of them being
that I can think of that I have in the
slides a famous game called The Binding
of Isaac dungeons can also be generated
so in what's the sort of like the main
unit of a dungeon and at least in the in
the context of Legend of Zelda if you
had to distill what comprises a dungeon
what's that the most fundamental unit
yes a room so we can almost look at this
if we picture it in terms of a 2d array
right
we have assuming that this is like index
1 1 in Lua
0 0 and other languages going left to
right top to bottom basically we have on
or off relative to each of these off on
on off off off each of the indexes in
this 2d array holds a room and so the
room has connections implicitly between
the other rooms if you wanted to go
let's say from this room here to the
room up above it
what's the offset in terms of the 2d
array how are we going from this room up
to this room so we're just going up a Y
level right so this is X level 3 Y level
3 if we wanted to go up to the next room
we need to load in if we're doing it to
Zelda way right and we're just going
where we're doing a transition between
one room to another what we need to do
is load in the room at this room minus
one on the Y and then perform the
transition and then set that to the
current room such that now we know we're
at Y level two X level three
that's our dungeon in the context of 2d
dungeons in the Legend of Zelda that's
as simple as it really is you have a 2d
grid of done of dungeon rooms each room
has its own collection of entities and
objects and connections to other rooms
but really all you all you do to sort of
fill a dungeon is fill an array in a
smart way such that there's no rooms
that are for example left by themselves
notice that every room in the dungeon
has at least one connection to another
room and that when you're maybe doing
your algorithm to create a convincing
dungeon let's say this room here has a
door on the right that has a lock right
we want to make sure that the key isn't
in that room because if it is we're
never going to be able to get to it
assuming that we come from another
direction
so when you're designing dungeons
procedurally you want to take these sort
of things into consideration and then
for example the boss room let's say this
is the boss room the boss room should
have
maybe a boss key or something like that
but the boss key should not be obviously
in that room it should be somewhere
maybe where there's a couple of rooms
before it that have a lock or a key so
that you know there's some sort of
challenge involved in your dungeon it's
not just random as random as we've done
before there has to be a little bit of
sort of conscious design on behalf of
your algorithms today we're doing things
completely random for illustration is
because a system like this is fairly
robust and complex but with some effort
you could create a simple dungeon
generator just using those mechanics
just make sure that you have lock doors
the locked doors can only open when you
have a key make sure the key exists in a
place that's accessible and sort of
create a chain of like a sort of like a
control flow model maybe via a graph of
some kind that represents your dungeon
and the progression thereof so that's
that's what a Zelda dungeon looks like
that's what a 2d dungeon in this sort of
perspective looks like and it looks it
will look similar to this in other game
engines it doesn't necessarily have to
be perfectly modeled as a screen with
screen high room going into another
screen of screen right room you can have
arbitrarily complex rooms that have
arbitrarily complex sizes and shapes but
you still need to make sure that the
connections going out of the rooms like
if you you could still model you know
left-right up-down if you want to you
could model arbitrary numbers of
connections between rooms just make sure
that you have puzzles that can be solved
that's the main sort of obstacle in
generating your dungeons here's the game
that I really like that uses the old
Legend of Zelda formula to very good
effect now it's called The Binding of
Isaac notice already we can instantly
see that it's top-down perspective it's
the entire width and height of the room
is the dungeon of the entire width and
height of the screen is the dungeon room
you have a map up here that sort of
shows you okay I'm in this room right
here I can go up I can go left I can go
right I can go down this room up here
with the yellow crown that's gonna be
locked behind some door with a key so we
need to have keys that spawn in any of
these rooms that are just
blindly accessible and Isaac does things
a little bit differently also in that it
generates keys and bombs randomly so
that you can actually get you don't
necessarily have to plant your keys in
very specific locations if your
algorithm is sufficiently accommodating
and complex enough you can just at the
end of every room have a chance to spawn
a key randomly and you know if you're
lucky or if you're not lucky and
assuming that the end of the dungeon
doesn't exist behind your locked doors
you can you have the opportunity to
still unlock those doors or not and just
go on throughout your dungeon as needed
in this case they don't lock the boss
doors so you can go through the boss
door regardless of whether you have a
key so they've accommodated for this
purely random approach and that just
goes to illustrate how you can still
take randomization using very complex
principles and produce games that are
extremely addicting and fun and don't
necessarily need to be super elaborate
the first thing okay so hitbox isn't
hurt box be the next topic so I want to
touch on in the code how we sort of do
dungeon generation in the game engine
here so I'm gonna open up there's a few
files so doorway notice in in in the
source distro there's a world folder
we've sort of categorized all of the
files that have to do with world
generation within that world folder we
have a doorway file we have a dungeon
file and we have a room file so the
dungeon file models the dungeon we just
all of the rooms that form our dungeon
just as a very high level top level data
structure it's actually very simple the
room is as we saw before the individual
unit of the dungeon so a dungeon is
effectively like a table of rooms and
then it models interact a mob it holds
the code for how we can transition
between them but that's sort of how we
can think about it when you have a game
level in general in this case dungeon is
sort of our game level you can model the
different subsets aspects of your level
via some data structure in this case
we've decided to make it room but if you
have just a platformer level maybe you
have regions or zones or anything just
little sub segments of your level that
you can transition between it's useful
to think in terms of that because from
an efficiency and performance standpoint
you want to dynamically probably load
certain levels one at a time certain
aspects certain components sub areas of
your level one at a time rather than
just the entire level at once because
depending on how sufficiently complex
and larger level is you could get to you
know exercising your computer's memory
constraints so don't want to do that so
in this case our algorithm is we have a
dungeon we have rooms we have one active
room that's only visible at one time
that's loaded in memory and then
whenever we transition between rooms we
want to have another room that gets
temporarily loaded so let's look at the
dungeon class here dungeon duo
so fourteen self dot rooms empty table
we're gonna fill that with rooms just
room objects self dot current room room
and then we're gonna pass it in the
player so that the player has access to
all the entities and objects they're in
and can do things like collision
detection which is very important and
also so that the entities in the room
can look at the player and then decide
what they want to do with their AI which
you can model arbitrarily complex the
whole init function of room lua is gonna
we're gonna show it here so in room dot
lua in that same world folder we've
instantiate the dungeon at a high level
we know the dungeon is a it's basically
a table of rooms so what's a room look
like well a room as we saw before what
are the what are the pieces that a room
needs in order to function was the room
have to sort of keep control of
so doors anything else so doors it has
to keep track of right because when we
touch a door we should transition to the
next room it should keep track of the
player so the player can update you keep
track of objects in the in the room like
switches as we saw in the example such
that you know they can update those and
Co has the player stepped on the switch
if he has open the doors and then
entities right you should keep track of
all of the creatures in the in the in
the room so that they can update they
can interact with each other the player
can hit them or they can hit the player
and you can model whatever interactions
you want to so we can see here oh and
another thing too obvious then probably
the most one of the more important
visual aspects of it we need to also
have a set of tiles that model what the
room looks like it's a container so
we're gonna draw you know we have a
corner a corner a corner a corner walls
on the sides walls on the top and bottom
and then a floor and so that's we need
to obviously draw the room before we
draw all of the other things and update
all the other things so tiles doorways
entities and objects so we can see here
we have tiles self that tiles gets an
empty table we have a function called
generate walls and floors entities empty
table we have a function called generate
entities and then objects equals empty
table we have a function called generate
objects and lastly doorways and then
here it's a because it's not necessarily
as complex as we need for a an entire
function we just have four doorways and
this is static I've chosen in this
example to have all the doorways always
be in the same place and sort of behave
in the same way but you could create a
more complex system whereby you
especially if you have an algorithm that
generates a dungeon dynamically and
maybe your rooms aren't necessarily hard
set maybe maybe you have a room right if
we go if we go back to our slides
earlier and let's say we're looking at
this room right here in the very center
we can see it has a doorway on the left
a doorway up top and a doorway to the
right but there's no doorway on the
bottom
and that that looks like an arbitrary
design decision on behalf of the
designers but if we look at this room up
top here we can see that it sort of
behaves in the same way there's a
doorway going to this room to the left
there's a doorway going to this room
down below but it doesn't have a doorway
up top and a doorway on the right
because there are no rooms going between
that room and those directions so when
you have a 2d array of dungeon rooms and
you want to model your doorways it can
be as simple as is there a room in that
direction if there is and you'll have
your data structure sort of laid out in
advance before you generate these
doorways if it does if it does not exist
don't make a door if it does exist make
a door and then make sure that when you
transition between the left from let's
say from the right to the left or from
the bottom to the top that you go to the
correct rooms at the correct indices in
your 2d sort of a room array does that
make sense
anybody have any questions so far as to
like how this works at a high level ok
awesome
so these doorways here are all because
of this dungeons completely random and
every time it always has doorways going
top bottom left and right we're always
just going to put four doorways going
top bottom left and right note that they
take a string denoting which direction
they are and this will become important
later on in the doorway class which we
see here is model as a separate class
false here just means is the door open
so by default we're going to close the
door and then self so that we have
access to the room from the doorway the
room should have a reference to the
player so that it can model interactions
between the entities and the player as
well as the objects on the player notice
that it has a render offset so if we
look at the game here
the tiles don't completely match up to
the width and height of the screen and
that's mainly a function of the virtual
height not mapping perfectly to 16 tiles
divided evenly by say
scene tiles so what I've done is I've
made the dungeon a little bit smaller
and I've and also the fact that the
doorways take up a couple extra tiles of
padding on their on their sides this
like sort of blank space up here we've
shifted everything inwards a little bit
we've made that we've made the dungeon
one tile smaller or two tiles smaller
width and height wise than the screen
and then we've just rendered offset by a
certain amount such that it's completely
centered we calculate how much padding
exists between the fully rendered
dungeon and whatever blank space is left
and just shift by half of that amount
and that's our render offset so that's
why that's what why render offset is
important in this case when you're
trying to center anything you typically
do it just by calculating an offset
calculate the width and height of what
if you're trying to draw calculate
whatever your width and height of your
screen is - that / - that's your render
offset and then this is this these two
fields here are interesting self dot
adjacent offset X and self dot adjacent
offset Y does anybody have a guess as to
sort of what this is used for yeah yes
exactly so drawing itself when it's the
adjacent room so when you load the next
room you're going to instantiate a room
just like this but by default it's going
to draw at 0 0 however if we want that
room to draw you know not right where we
are obviously if we're in the current
room we don't want the next room drawing
right on top of where we are because
then it's just gonna lay it right on top
of the room we're in we want to draw it
if we're going to the right we want to
draw it a screen width to the right if
we're drawing it to the left we want to
draw a screen width to the left and same
thing on the y-axis the screen height
above or below it so adjacent offset X
or Y we just add two when we draw the
room and that'll have the effect of
rendering it separately from from the
room that we're currently in I can try
and draw have an illustration here so if
we have our room here this is our
current room so self current room
and if we let's say we have a doorway
here right that's a doorway object the
player is here he collides with that
object it's gonna trigger a transition
to a room up above so what we do is we
load in a new room right away we always
have a pointer called self dot next room
and this is all kept track of in the
dungeon Lua file but self dot next room
by default it's going to be nil but when
we transition from the current room to
the next room right we should set that
to something so self dot current room is
going to be the same but when we trigger
this when we trigger this collision self
dot next room this is going to be equal
to just a new room and then we get which
doorway we're in we figure it out we
figure out which direction we're moving
in technically and then if we're moving
up then we just pass in a we set it
adjacent offset Y in this case to
negative screen height if it's below we
set it to positive screen height and we
said it if we go here it's going to be
negative screen width the adjacent X
will be negative screen width and then
positive screen width on the X if we're
moving to the right and so this sort of
adjacent we can see the if we do like X
Y I think that'll be that the adjacent
offset and so we end up when we draw our
transition going from bottom to up in
this case we just tween the camera to
this value so we have a camera right
this is our camera and it's going to be
looking here by default so camera X and
camera Y those are values in our code as
well when we trigger this collision on
the doorway and we have current room
here which is at 0 0 and then we
have this room here which is at zero
minus or plus our adjacent offset Y
which is negative screen height so it
has the effect of making it negative
screen height on the Y our camera X
miracle recall love dot graphics
translate is our camera so all we do is
we just tween that we say okay here's
our cam X is gonna be here and cam why
it's getting a little bit messy I
apologize but our camera x and y are
here and then over time we're going to
tween that up into the next rooms x and
y which is calculated it's just X plus
adjacent offset X y plus adjacent offset
Y and then once once this camera has
shifted from here up to here or
whichever direction we're going whether
it's up down left or right once we've
completed that we can normalize
everything again back to 0-0 by doing
self dot current room equals what's the
what do we need to do if we're if we're
gonna put everything back to and let's
say let's say I want to make this this
room the new current room what do I need
to do so we have current room and we
have next room if I want the current
room to become the next room all I need
to do is say self dot current room
equals self dot next room right
and then once that happens jacent off so
what happens to the adjacent offset X&Y
over the next room they get set to zero
right I want to take I want to take this
room that we've offset up here and I
just want to make it the center of the
gaming world again I want to just put it
at zero zero so we can do this exact
same calculation by just setting
adjacent offset X or Y to a negative or
positive screen hider screen with
relative to zero zero so what I'm going
to do is just set the adjacent offset of
x and y of the next room which is now
current room to zero and it's going to
draw it right back at 0 0 and then
camera X and camera Y are also going to
be set to 0 0 and this is going to have
the effect of looking as if we're going
up and staying there but in reality
we're just going up and then instantly
shifting everything back to 0 0
including the player entities and
switches of that room so it's purely an
illusion but it allows us to simulate
this sort of infinite exploring a
dungeon effect does that make sense is
the overall flow of how this works make
sense okay so it's a little bit messy
there hopefully I was able to illustrate
the overall algorithm for how the
infinite dungeon generator works where
did we leave off on we were in oh yeah
we were in the anit function of the room
so let's take a look at a few of the
functions that comprise that so generate
walls and floors this is very simple
very similar to what we've looked at
before with like tile maps in Mario for
example where we just go from Y to X and
then we just pick a random ID or not
random ID well it is random ID for some
of it but sometimes we need an explicit
ID so remind me what does the ID
actually map to when we're you know
drawing tiles to the screen if we want
to give a tile an ID what is that what
should that map to yeah
the frame in the spritesheet that's
correct
it isn't have to for all game engines
for all implementations but it's the
easiest thing to do is just to give it
your Thailand ID that you can then just
draw you can index into your sprite
sheet at that ID it's just very very
simple lightweight clean approach to
modeling if we can see here id gets ID
after we've sort of figured out what ID
we want now how do we determine like
let's say I want to draw let's say for
example like this tile here no says it's
a corner tile how would I what do I need
to do to basically s I'm gonna die
before I even have the chance to to show
you while I avoid enemies if I wanted to
draw that top-left corner
what am I sort of looking for I still
taking damage anyway relative to X and y
what am I looking for what x and y does
that does that tile need assuming
everything starts one one on the top
left and goes down to height and width
of the overall dungeon what is the X Y I
need to be of that top left corner needs
to be one right so if that's one one
basically the top left corner that ID
should be equal to the corner sprite the
top left corner sprite specifically what
about the top right corner sprite what
should the X be
sorry yes with exactly what's the why
still gonna be one what about the bottom
left with coma height and in the bottom
right
oh sorry the bottom left should be 1
comma height bottom right should be with
comma height and so basically checking
the position of each tile is how we can
infer its ID which is what we're doing
in the source code here if X is 1 and Y
is 1 okay top left corner and notice
that we've put these down into constants
that we've put into constant Lua just
for readability so we can instantly see
okay I should say ID to tile top left
corner not some arbitrary number that's
our index into the tile sheet at like
maybe like 40 something or whatever it
is bottom left is 1 and height top right
is width and one and then bottom right
is width and height and we can sort it's
it's readable we can just sort of see at
a glance what we're doing we're sort of
conditionally generating all of our
tiles if none of those are true and then
X is 1 what's what's that tile if X is
one but it's not a corner
it's a left-hand wall and the same thing
as if it's the width
it's a right-hand wall and if Y is one
it's a top wall if Y is height it's a
bottom wall and then if it's none of
those it's gotta be a floor exactly so
that's that's basically how we generate
the overall it's very it's a very easy
simple generation algorithm what I've
done is for randomization here we have a
actually a table of potential left walls
potential right Waals potential top and
bottom and then we just describe it a
random value within there based on
however large that is and that gives us
variable we can see it it's it's we have
random whoops every time I generate it
so take note of maybe some of the tiles
visually that you can see there on the
map notice that they changed notice that
the switch has also changed
notice that they changed again so
everything is variable we have a little
bit of visual variety this is what we
did essentially with Mario we changed
the tile set and a topper set only now
we're just changing we have only one
tile sheet but several variations of the
same tile therein so all we need to do
is pick a random variation of whatever
tile and that involves us looking at the
sprite sheet picking out which
individual tiles which separate tiles
map to the specific type of tile and
then just picking a random value from
that table that's how that works
so a couple things I think left to show
relative to the dungeon generation so 48
we have generate entities so entities
are here view we have their names right
some of the entities we saw skeletons
bats slimes ghosts spiders it's a very
light weight function like it's not it -
it's like 15 or 20 lines but we're
generating you know a bunch of different
kinds of entities because what we've
done we take we we basically take a
random type from that table we create an
entity and then using what we've defined
in a
global table called entity deaths we
take out what sort of matters in terms
of generating each individual entity the
characteristics thereof and we just put
it in simple data form this is sort of
like the the segue into data-driven
design for your game if you look at
entity deaths here we can just see that
all of our entities are a sequence of
data so we have up here we have player
right online ten player gets a table we
give them walk speed we have a table of
animations so he's got a walk left
animation a walk right animation a walk
down animation all of those have their
frames their interval their texture
everything is just clean data right
there's no logic here really it's just
flags or values simple things you could
give this you could give anybody who has
sort of the basic knowledge of what
we're doing this file and what may be
some textures and say hey I want you to
design I want you to layout basically
all of that that's involved and what
makes a skeleton sort of rent it to the
screen like give them like create all
the animations for them give them the
give us that give the those animations
their time and give them the exact
frames maybe maybe skeleton should have
health and maybe health should be equal
to ten on a skeleton or something like
that there's not really any like
programming going on here but we were
describing everything in our game as
data and that's important thing in
complex games that have you know fairly
complex systems but that can be modeled
via some attributes you can just
describe your entities and data and then
lay your engine parse this information
and then create your entities
programmatically you allow you sort of
shift the burden from the programmer to
the designer a little bit and you afford
your design team you and maybe other
people who aren't as comfortable with
programming the ability to modify the
game engine add things to the game
without having to go through the bulk of
your engine code and do anything too
fancy in this case it's simple all we're
doing is just we're creating animations
and assigning a texture to each of these
individual things but I alluded to this
last week you could have a file that
maybe describes something like a goblin
we'll see this at the end of
which has maybe like a flag for is it
flammable how much health does it have
what are its animations what skills does
it have
what's its attack strength what's its
defense where where does it spawn
typically by putting all these
attributes together and having your
engine sort of parse this you can create
depending on how come how many fields
you have you can create a very complex
like potential list of things in your
game whether they're entities with other
weapons whether their items abilities
anything you want to whether they're
levels even based solely on just data so
this is a holy grail of design and
development when you get into especially
very complex games like RPGs where you
can have skills that are you know have
particle effects and do different damage
to different things and you have
entities that are maybe you want them
some to set on fire some to be
electrocuted maybe some you don't maybe
some melt when they touch something
create a bunch of flags create a
function that parses this and generates
entities as a result and you just allow
yourself an incredible boost in
productivity no longer do you need to
create a spider class a ghost class a
bat class it's all unnecessary all you
need to do is define what sort of
attributes does a bat have what
attributes does it ghost have what
attributes does a skeleton have and
anybody can therefore mod your game as a
result of this all they need to do is
know what attributes a potential entity
can have and your design team is all the
more productive as a result so that's a
sort of spiel on why this is relevant
we've implemented a very basic version
of this just for the sake of modeling
animations but we don't need a separate
class for all the different entities in
our game world we just need basically
and in the context of this game what are
their animations so that's entity deaths
that's how it's working if we're looking
at room to AH at line 48 all it's doing
is getting animations this is by the way
your function that takes in these
definitions and creates your entities
they should be looking for looking into
that they pull that definition and then
just parse out each individual relevant
piece of data and then just construct
some relevant information or attach a
relevant flag to that entity that your
game engine can then later parse the for
the flammable example if you do an
attack and that attack is of type fire
and it collides with an entity and that
entity dot flammable is true that should
trigger some behavior but you don't need
to do anything terribly complex and you
can assign this to any relevant 'ti
thereafter so just a simple way of
getting very complex behavior for your
game objects entities whatever you want
modeling them as data rather than
thinking about it in terms of classes so
that's that does anybody have any
questions just like sort of how that
works or how it's why it's viable or why
it's useful okay a couple last things
we'll look at really fast in room so on
line 80 to generate objects so we did
this very very similarly last week where
we just had a game object class notice
that it takes itself a definition for a
switch that definition is in game
objects Lua
switch here's a little bit more sort of
data modeling something like a switch
it's got its type of switch its frame is
2 by default so width and height of 16
it's not solid player can walk over it
its default state is unpressed so when
it gets spawned into the game its
unpressed and then it's got two
potential states unpressed and pressed
and each of those states have a frame so
all we need to do to render it is say
what's its current state render the
state da frame and then now we don't
need to do anything to that's basically
all we need to do in order to render it
at the right point your game engine
therefore needs to look at your object
and look at its state and look at its
potential states index into that state
and then look at the inn and pull the
frame from that but it affords you sort
of infinite flexibility you can now have
like
I don't know gallant maybe you have a
glowing state and maybe there's a frame
in that sprite sheet that's loud allows
it to glow and you could just change it
to glowing whenever you want and it'll
just render appropriately so very
flexible approach to modeling data 149
in room so we're almost done with the
dungeon here so 149 is our update
function all it does basically is
iterate through everything and update it
including Ida basically all the entities
so for every entity sort of if it's less
than if its health is less than equal to
0 its dead if it's dead
then don't render it which we see down
in render but if it's not dead and self
dot player collides with it and the
player is not invulnerable
then we should damage the player go
invulnerable and if the players health
is 0 change the game over so notice how
readable this is when you model your
entities like this as well all you
really need to do is just check for
certain flags or functions and you can
do arbitrarily complex tests like this
because entities can be dead or not
because entities can be invulnerable or
not and then because entities are all X
Y width height based things in our game
and collides just expects them to have
that all we just do is play sound damage
the player all dammit what it what does
damage do offhand what do we think it
does exactly just take a wild guess and
say it subtracts from health it does so
self entity damage just takes in a
number and subtract that from health
that's all it does
go and vulnerable what does that do
it does it takes it prevents you from
taking damage for that many seconds all
but all that really does is just set a
flag which we I've alluded to quite a
bit already an arbitrary flag that you
can model via data or some other means
every entity has an invulnerable flag
and if it's invulnerable then the engine
should look for that and change the
rendering and the mechanics of the
entity accordingly and then lastly here
just simple if the player health is
equal to zero which it might be after we
take sufficient damage change the game
over that's all it does and then for
every object just as we do with every
entity update the object and if the
player collides with it then trigger its
on collide function and this can be a
function that you arbitrarily create
depending on the needs of your object if
we look up here for example every time
we create a room we generate objects in
the room we insert into objects a switch
which we saw before in game objects Lua
and takes an X and a Y in this case we
just make sure that the X and Y is a
random number between the top left of
the map and the bottom right of the map
within the padding that it has we get a
reference to that object and then we
define our con collide function so what
we do is we say if it's unpressed
so recall that we have a state in the
game object definition if it's unpressed
change it depressed that's all we really
need to do and then notice here for K
doorway so for every doorway in doorways
self doorways set that doorway open is
true and then play a door sound so our
on collide function just interacts with
other things in the game world and just
very simple things but has a pretty you
know interesting sort of mechanic like
we have a tic damage off the bat there
because my spawning isn't perfect but it
changed from notice that it changed its
state from unpress depressed because it
went from the one sprite to all go into
another room so we can see that take
some damage on the way go in another
room notice the sprite it sort of looks
like it's unpressed right because the
game objects default state is unpressed
and then on collide triggers when I go
on top of it it changes state which has
an effect on what rent gets rendered and
it's on collide function just called
which opened up every doorway in the
room so simple like 15 lines of code but
pretty compelling interesting behavior
for the sake of our dungeon like it's it
adds a lot as simple as that is now we
sort of feel like we're interacting with
our game world a little bit so that's
that's how that sort of works and then
lastly rendering on line 188 just go
through all of our tiles render all the
tiles we've seen this before
render all the doorways render all the
objects render all the entities if
they're not dead right if they're dead
then don't render them and then this bit
here will take it we'll take a look at
at the end which is stenciling so notice
that when I walk through doors well
first of all notice that I can't walk
through doors if they're closed which is
important so when you collide with your
doorway objects if doorway dot open is
false
shouldn't trigger the room switch right
but if I open the doors they're now all
set to recall door open is now equal to
true so they've changed their rendering
so now they're they're rendering open
doorways if I walk through it notice
that it looks as if the player walks
underneath the tiles but I'm drawing the
tiles before the player and one approach
that you might think to do when sort of
creating this believable appearance of
walking through a doorway is say okay
I'll just render the player after I
render the doorway or before I render
the doorways right so render all the
doorway has last but it doesn't quite
work out because the sprite actually
starts right here so what what does
somebody think is gonna happen if I were
to draw the doorway after the player
exactly the player would disappear as
soon as he gets to this little bit of
line right here which is not very
convincing and actually I'll try right
now to take away the stenciling so we
can see what that looks like so if I
just take away the stenciling here and
then I just render whoops can't type
today so I'm gonna go ahead do that well
first of all the rendering order hat is
such that now the doorways render after
the player before the player so he just
walks right over them right so I'm just
walking I'm just walking over the walls
that's not compelling and if I were to
do something as simple as change the
rendering order so right now the
doorways render first I'll just render
the doorways after the player so right
here I took that out right No so right
now if they render before the player I
want to render them after the player and
I'm going to just run it and then going
to step on the switch and then yep
notice we get some weird behavior - like
these heads getting cut off like that's
and the other entities as well right
in that case couldn't really tell but
yeah very weird rendering behavior and
what we do to fix that is we create
what's called a stencil so basically try
and get a screenshot here I can I can
show first let me fix the changes that
it just made right and then if I go back
into the code here
so a stencil is just and we'll see a
slide on this in a little bit but a
stencil is just a basically any sort of
arbitrary shape that you want that you
draw onto the screen it's invisible but
it determines whatever whatever gets
drawn on top of that stencil it
determines whether or not that thing
gets rendered so I have a stencil going
basically from here onwards to the next
room so right about where the doorway
hits the archway because that's where we
want the players head to look like it
disappears stencil going here I have the
stencil going right here and right here
and on the right side as well and what
that does is I've set the stencil to say
whatever passes through this stencil
during the sort of stencil testing
period which is we'll all we do is we
just draw the player during that time
but basically if it's on the stencil
don't render it and so what that has the
effect of is we draw that we still draw
the doorways before the player so the
player walks in and he's drawn above
this part but as soon as he hits the
stencil he's not drawn it's just all
those basically what it does is it draws
the character to the stencil and not to
the to the actual canvas and so we get
convincing this sort of if you want sort
of convincing layered weird visual
effects like that stenciling is is an
approach okay and then that's all this
is
so this stencil functional about
graphics dot stencil it takes in a
function this is what's going to run
during the actual stenciling process
it's gonna draw I draw four rectangles
all those rectangles are just the those
archways right perfectly layered over
them such that it goes into the next
room and then we do notice that it says
replace and then one so we replace any
pixel that gets drawn to that stencil
with the stencil value of 1 and then we
only draw things that are less than 1
during the stencil test which means
anything that didn't get ascribed a
value of 1 which means that if the
player went over the stencil got a pixel
value of 1 that's gonna be false he's
not going to be drawn to the screen yeah
question was if you have a stencil
because you can do with an arbitrary
shape you could create lighting systems
where some areas of dark and some areas
are light I want to say possibly the
thing is I'm not 100% sure whether
stenciling allows you to do like whether
love 2ds stenciling allows you to do
like arbitrary numbers of stuff like
what I basically am not sure if it's on
or off or a gradient typically if I were
to do our lighting system like that I
would probably draw like a faux lighting
system one you can use a lighting kit
like box 2d lights which a lot which
does really compelling cool lights for
you or sort of a cruder way to do it but
possibly realistic would be to draw a
shape that fits whatever you want to be
your darkness and then render it at an
opacity that's less than 100% so like so
you would have like let's say you have a
room and let's say maybe like two like
the size of it or like kind of shadowy
you draw like black rectangles there
right but instead of drawing those black
rectangles at 255 alpha you draw them at
like 200 or 150 or something like that
and so you can still see what's
underneath them but it looks as if they
are you know sort of a shadow and you
can use gradient effects do the same
thing if you want to like have a shadow
that's darker going lighter
I believe you can draw rectangles with a
gradient effect in love 2d I'd have to
look into a little bit more but you
would you would look to do something
like that draw a gradient of shadow via
some rectangle or some arbitrary shape
to simulate lighting in that case and
you could accomplish something similar
to that and there are a lot of other
crazy cool ways I've seen lighting done
in 2d but that's probably off hand the
simplest way that I could think of doing
it so that's stenciling and that's
basically that's basically it for the
dungeon generation which is arguably the
most important part and also we we
looked earlier at the sort of transition
mechanic and we'll look at the
transition mechanic a little bit more
and a little bit but let's take a
five-minute for right now and then come
back to that and see some more stuff
alright welcome back to lecture five
Legend of Zelda so before the break we
talked about a bunch of different things
Dungeon generation being foremost among
them
now we'll actually start talking about
things like hit boxes and hurt boxes as
we can see here on the screen so a hit
box is a rectangle basically that's how
I fitted it in the distro but we can see
here there's a few different sort of
rectangles overlapping we have the green
rectangles here these are hurt boxes
these are where you can get hurt and
then this is a hit box this is where you
can hit something and so games like
especially with fighting games and a lot
of games of you know fairly complex
interactions and complex entities that
have weapons or particles things like
that that all do damage you'll see a lot
of sort of complicated overlapping and
adjust our arrangement of these
rectangles that sort of bring about how
things interact with each other in terms
of collision and doing damage and
affecting other entities in this case
he's doing like a an attack that goes
from the left to the right it's a low
attack only his foot essentially a
little bit inwards but essentially his
foot does damage whereas the rest of him
is vulnerable like if someone were to
come up to him from up above and attack
him it would it would do some damage and
there's minecraft and it shows you how
the same sort of principle applies to 3d
games as well in this case the what you
see there are all hurt boxes those are
all where things can get hurt even
though those are a few of those things
are items so that only really affects
whether or not the player collides with
them and picks them up but that's
basically the difference between hit
boxes and hurt boxes the distro I think
I accidentally called the file hurt box
so when I push it up it's going to be
renamed a hit box because that's what we
use it for but the what is offhand in
the in this game what do we need a hit
box for yeah
may attach my sword and the reason that
we need a hitbox for that is why yes and
why can't we just use the players
position X Y width and height as a
direction as well and also it needs
deaths that's it essentially it's hurt
box right so that's for those two
reasons it has a direction that we need
to sort of act as its reference point
for generating a hitbox to inflict
damage on other entities and we need to
use the player's main hitbox that hurt
box that already has to see if something
hit it the player maybe from another
side or something like that so let's go
ahead and take a look here the main a
bit of code that deals with the hitbox
in this case is one gonna be hurt box
should be hit box but we can see this is
literally just a rectangle class X Y
width and a height self dot X self dot y
self not with stuff that height equals
all those things that's all you need for
it for a pit box literally box just all
you need are those fields and then you
can do simply collides just like you do
entity entity collides hurt box yes no
true or false because recall collides
expects X Y width or height and it's
defined in entity Lua so if we go up to
the player States so recall last week we
introduced them the idea of having the
player maintain its own collection of
states in a state machine as opposed to
just the game world having a state
machine that you know influences whether
we're at the Start screen the placed
play state screen whatever we want to
divide our game up into we have entity
States as well now one of those is the
so we have the idle in the walk state
those are very similar to last weeks
where the if not idle state they're just
standing still and walking state they're
moving and then their animation changes
accordingly the swing sword state is a
new state and what this does is the
player presses spacebar it triggers this
swing sword state there's a new
animation so we go into the swing sword
animation relative to which direction
we're in and
we get that direction and then we
calculate the X Y width and height of
whatever our hurt box it should be
hitbox is going to be for the sword when
no the sword hit something so that
hitbox if it's facing to the left it's
gonna be eight pixels wide by 16 tall
which is roughly the left side of the
player and then we just calculate the
X&Y depending on which position we're in
it should be roughly centered based on
whatever position the players Direction
the player is looking at and so that we
then instantiate that hurt box here we
call it a self dot sword hurt box and
then all we really need to do is what in
our game loop to check to see if we've
hit an entity
we just need to loop over the entities
in our room
the current room right here so every
entity in the dungeons current room dot
entities if the entity collides with our
sword hurt box sword hit box then we saw
this method before entity damage one and
then hit enemy play that's as simple as
it is and recall in room da lua if an
entity's health drop below one drop to
zero it would just trigger it to become
dead right and so that's all we need
effectively and then we have some
additional logic to make sure that the
animation only plays one time and then
once it has played one time change its
state to idle and then we can press
spacebar repeatedly within that same
state just to keep swinging if we want
to and it'll just restart the animation
and restart the hitbox being
instantiated and so that's all we really
need to do for that now I have some
lines of code here at the bottom of the
sword swing state lua and player sword
swing sword state and what these do is
sometimes it's useful when you're
programming to sort of see where your
collision boxes are right because you
don't necessarily know if everything is
lined up perfectly you know when you're
detecting collision between different
entities you want to just check to see
are this rectangles actually overlapping
when this triggers so all you need to do
in order to visually see this at a
glance and you may have seen this before
in other games or debug modes of games
is just draw line rectangles and then
just give them the X Y width and height
that you want to look at right so here
I'm going to go ahead and save this and
I'm going to run the basically
uncommented it because by default I
don't want it showing I don't want the
they're pink rectangles I don't want
them display on the screen unless I want
to do debugging so I'm going to
uncomment them down here notice it sets
the color to 255 0 255
that's magenta I'm going to run this
turn it down a little bit nothing looks
particularly different but when I swing
my sword notice that there's a little
rectangle and the rectangles are 100%
perfect necessarily there they give the
player a little bit of an advantage
that's that's like up above like his
hitbox is barely anything up above in
the in the actual animation but in the
in the collision I give it quite a wide
wide berth and so that's how you can add
a glance sort of see whether your things
are interact or interacting
appropriately there's lines of code that
do the same thing for the other states
the entity walking and idle States if
you want to sort of look at those and
see not only the players swinging the
sword but also the other entities and
the collision boxes they have and just
to check whether or not they're
overlapping appropriately or to change
them or do whatever you want with them
but that's a nice way to sometimes it's
hard to debug collision if you can't see
exactly what's going on because it's
often just in terms of X Y width and
height and so on and so forth with
offsets and such it can be kind of a
pain and we're sort of difficult to
track down certain bugs that way so just
draw to the screen you can apply that
same logic to a lot of things in your
game world that you can fish that are
maybe hidden but you want to see sort of
visually just draw shapes or draw
different things for them so you can see
what's going on so that's how the hitbox
and hurt box work for our player and you
can easily just spawn more hit boxes for
other entities if you want to if you
wanted to give them States or maybe you
want to create projectiles that are
offensive maybe just create projectiles
and then shoot projectiles in a specific
direction but assign a hitbox to that
projectile if you want to or just use
the projectiles X Y width and height and
then you can calculate a collision that
way just treat it like a game object or
an entity it's up to you or a separate a
superclass altogether but that's
hitboxes and hurt boxes in a nutshell
anybody have any questions as to how
those sort of work ok cool so let's go
on to the next topic so events so I
spoke of this earlier events are just a
nice way to sort of say when something
happens do this block of code and you
can do this anywhere and you can
decouple it sort of from like maybe two
different objects interact with each
other but you don't want them to sort of
pass references back and forth between
each other and to sort of bloat your
code maybe you want the code for that
check to happen not inside your main
loop you want to sort of abstract it out
to some sort of other function like
instantiate events and then have your
main rendering and update logic be sort
of free of all this conditional stuff so
you create an event you say on some
event so maybe like on player or walk
and then you just update some maybe a
label on the top right of the screen
that gives the players X Y and you just
say that X Y is equal to that player's X
Y I mean aside from the fact that you
could just literally draw up the players
X Y but it's the same principle you can
update some value somewhere separate
from another entity and then just wait
for an event arbitrarily defined event
that you then broadcast later so let's
say I want a broadcast swing sword I
have a swing sword event so whenever the
player presses space not only do they do
all the code that we saw before but they
swing sword and then we say when you
swing sword pass in the XY of wherever
they swung the sword and so then you can
say okay on swing sword look at all the
entities and see whether or not the
hitbox that XY collides with them and
you can sort of take out the logic from
where you had it before and put it in
some other centralized location if you
want to more sort of representative I
think of this model is the idea of an
achievement system where instead of
every frame and you can have you know
the games have like a ridiculous number
of achievements some games have like a
thousand achievements you don't want to
put the test for every one of those
1,000 achievements necessarily inside of
your like update logic right you can
instead just broadcast an event for all
of the different things that influence
whether those achievements are met so
whether player needs to get 100 kills in
a game or 100 coins whether they need to
like jump off some ledge you just have
events that model all these interactions
event on
pick up coin do this increment some
times some counter that's stored
somewhere else and event dot on kill
creature right where kill creatures
triggers every time you literally a
creature is set from dead dead as as
false the dead is true maybe whenever
the player jumps you do a on jump
function and then you can test to see
whether or not in that code you can test
to see whether they jumped off that
ledge and then if that happens you have
your achievement system but you don't
have all these if statements and all
these tests happening inside your your
sort of imperative game loop you can
just sort of a like pseudo
asynchronously check for all of them
given a sufficiently detailed event
system in your game and so the library
that we'll use just to show this a
little bit is in the knife library that
we saw before with timer timer on timer
dot every time a tween in the knife
library there's a sub module called
event which allows you to call event dot
on give it a name and a function so on
player jump off a player jump you know
function if player dot position is you
know by some cliff for some area that's
relevant then call this block of code
increment you know or set the
achievement to true event dispatch
dispatch an event when something happens
so if player jumps so with you press the
spacebar event dispatch jump and then
just whatever values that your callback
function needs let's say you want to
check to see what they've on the cliff
well if you want to check to see whether
they've jumped off that specific cliff
you're gonna need to check their XY
position presumably so you can just pass
in optional parameters via event dot
dispatch you can say okay dispatch the
event that the player jumped and say
that the player jumped at X Y and so
this function callback is going to have
access to the X Y it's gonna say okay on
jump I see I got I'm getting my callback
called with player X player dot Y and it
happens - oh it's not at the cliff so
nothing happens or it is the cliff so
the achievement jump off cliff
is true and this test now is not
happening every single frame which
otherwise would potentially and it's not
blocking up your update logic for your
player jumping right the player are the
jumping logic inside player the player
jump state doesn't need to know doesn't
need to ask whether or not we've jumped
off a cliff that's something that we
should just delegate to our achievement
file or whatever you want and that's
sort of the flexibility that events
afford you so we use event I'll touch on
this a little bit briefly here but
basically if we go to the player Walk
State online
21:39 first of all we're checking for
input here right we're just saying if we
press the left right up or down the
direction is that walk left walk right
so on and so forth and then if and then
what we do is we call entity walk state
update so this base walk state code that
exists in entity so that we can let let
every single entity have this code all
it does just to check to see whether or
not the player or entity that it belongs
to hit a wall and if it did then set
their bumped equals true and that what
all that does is just a flag that says
okay the player bumped a wall okay what
why is that relevant because then after
we call that we can say okay if we bump
the wall and this only happens in the
player walk state if we're looking to
the left temporarily adjust our position
because when you when it bumps you it
like knocks you back out back into the
world but we're gonna re bump our
position in to wherever we collided
we're going to look at every doorway and
then we're going to say if we collided
with that doorway and it's open then
we're going to shift it to the center of
the doorway so that it doesn't look as
if the player is walking through the
wall we're gonna set it to like wherever
the wall is the or wherever the door is
the very center of the doorway and then
we're gonna call event dispatch shift
and in that direction so shift left
shift right shift up and shift down
and so all of these these four different
cases are going to say okay the player
has hit a doorway I have a function
somewhere event dot on shift down shift
left shift right shift up that's gonna
trigger what the next room it's going to
trigger us moving to the next room and
also the next room spawning and the
camera sort of shifting position so the
code for this is in dungeon so we're
gonna go ahead and look at dungeon so
right here on line 29 through 43 event
dot on shift left shift right shift up
shift down and what that does is we have
another function called begin shifting
which takes in an X and a y- virtual
width virtual with negative virtual
height virtual height does anybody
recall why we need to pass those numbers
in there if we're shifting left and
we're passing a negative virtual width
what do you think that numbers gonna be
so recall every room has an adjacent
offset x and a y that renders that room
with that offset basically added to it
its x and a y so if we've been shifting
to the left
negative virtual width is gonna be the x
offset because that room needs to needs
to be rendered a screen width to the
left right and so on for the right
virtual width it adds a virtual wit to
the x offset the adjacent x offset and
then virtual height negative and
positive first shift up and shift down
so begin shifting basically it's the
gist of this is it's a tween operation
so we start here we call timer tween
just takes a value and interpolates it
so self we have a camera X and a camera
Y right I'm gonna equal shift X and
shift Y eventually so shift X and shift
Y being the adjacent offset that we're
gonna need to shift the camera by so
camera X and camera why are they both
start at 0 always when the room gets
completely finalized
so if we if the shift X is virtual width
negative virtual width because we're
shifting left then it's going to tween
the camera going from right to left over
the span of a second right and then the
player the player X and player Y those
are basically set up here to the
opposite end of the room the next room
so if the player is going from the top
of the room to the bottom of the next
room it needs to get its X&Y put in that
position the bottom part of the next
room or the left part the left part of
the next room if they're moving from the
right right or the right part if they're
moving for the left and the bottom part
if they're moving up and apart if
they're moving down so that's what that
does puts them in the right position on
the next room twins both of them the
camera and the player because the player
needs to keep moving to the next room
and the camera needs to shift up when
it's finished we call finish shifting
which is just a function that sets
basically everything to zero it says the
current room to the next room it sets
the camera x and all that stuff all to
zero and then all the entities and
objects there and all get set to zero so
we are there off set to zero so that
everything is basically right at zero
zero again just like it was at the very
beginning and then last but not least
when we get into the new room we start
with the doors all open and then when we
get into the net and into the room here
because this is all done in the finished
function recall this will only happen
after the tween is completed every
doorway is going to get set to false
open equals false so all the doors will
close as soon as we get into the next
room after we perform the tween
operation and then we'll play a door
sound so that's that's the code involved
in actually doing the shift operation so
we were able to trigger it we don't have
to necessarily do that code from the
player walk State we just say you know
if the players collided with the doorway
then dispatch an event that is handled
by dungeon because dungeon has access to
current room next room and all the stuff
that it needs to actually perform the
transition so we have the two that are
sort of decoupled but they work well in
tandem with
one another so anybody have questions as
to sort of how this works okay that's
the that's essentially the dungeon
scrolling just it's a tween operation
it's a camera a temporary room gets
rendered we move to the temporary room
everything gets set back to zero and
then just a it's a while loop of that
sort of behavior effectively and we use
the event library to sort of clean up
that whole aspect and sort of screen
scrolling here just another
demonstration we went over it in detail
but this is a nice gift I found that
sort of encapsulate what that means
stenciling is something that we saw
earlier and if we look at this as a
stencil so these we can pretend that
these are the circle the heart and that
rectangle our stencil and then we want
to draw this gray rectangle on top of
those stencils we can use the stencil to
mask out specific parts which which
would otherwise be pretty tough to do I
mean it's hard to necessarily like maybe
individually render pixels or create a
shape that sort of looks like this much
easier for a lot of very interesting
visual effects just use a stencil of
arbitrary shape and size and you can use
images too you can use images of
stencils to create some pretty cool
effects we went over it before when I
talked about the archway so I won't go
over it into much more detail but again
you can look at that in the where it was
it exactly it was in the room function
room class sorry down here at the bottom
so lines 213 to 229 recall they're a
stencil function the couple functions in
particular that you need to use our love
dog graphic stencil which draws the
stencils and then loved our graphics
that set stencil test which compares the
stencil values to some value and draws
them whether or not that condition is
true so we have our function here which
draws four rectangles those are all the
archways it replaces any pixels that get
drawn to those rectangles with the value
one the stencil value one
so stencil value is just like a hidden
value that determines whether stencils
get whether it
a image will get drawn if it's being
stenciled or not set stencil test means
that we're looking for anything less
than one and we'll draw that and because
the player is going to be one if it's on
any of those stencil rectangles it will
not draw the player if it overlaps with
those stencil rectangles and so that's
just that's in general how it works and
you can do there's a lot of different
comparisons you can do greater than one
you can do iterative stenciling so that
you can increment a value it good you
can have stencil values go between 1 & 0
and 255 there's a lot of interesting
effects you can get with that but the
general use that we just saw is you know
set the values to 1 and then check to
see whether they're less than 1 if you
want to draw them if you want to not
draw them anybody have questions it's
like how stenciling works and how these
functions work yeah
when you drop there thank you
yes so the it's like having the the
stencil rectangles go over the doorway
so that the player will not get drawn
went underneath them the I go back to a
slide that has it the stencils are here
right right I had to go through and
figure out the exact XY that I needed
for them and there is a you can what you
can do is you can take that stencil
function that draws the rectangles and
you can just like take it out of the
stencil test and see you'll actually be
able to see where the exact rectangles
are because then it'll just literally
draw the rectangles but here basically
right over it right between here and
where it would be on the next room so
that when we go from here over into the
next room it still stencils them right
here the player is going to go over them
it's going to set its stencil value to
one it's checking for anything less than
less than one to render so it's gonna
fail the test then it's going to not
draw that player at that point so
effectively just masking out the player
because we're assigning it to the right
stencil value or doing the right
comparison for it but yeah that's
effectively yet just using it to because
we were in a situation where our tiles
didn't cleanly lend themselves to
drawing over the player which you could
do you could draw the shadow part
underneath the archway part and then
just change the rendering order but the
spritesheet that we had didn't afford us
that flexibility so we went through
women with a little more interesting
stenciling approach to getting it done
we looked at this earlier so game design
via data rather than you know a bunch of
logic so the more you can sort of get
towards modeling your anything in your
game like data like this the more
flexible your engine is the easier it is
for people to mod your game which is
hugely important and the easier it is
for you to let designers take charge of
actually creating assets for your game
so here we've created an arbitrary
collection of data and you could get as
complex with this as you want to the
only thing that really matters is
whether your game engine supports those
fields and
acts on those fields accordingly but
once it does I mean the more things you
add the more possibilities you have for
adding new things so Goblin we have
health strength so strength should be
accounted for in our game engine and
this is we're talking in just the
general abstract sense now let's say we
were like making an RPG or something or
maybe maybe maybe this is part of our
Zelda game if we got a little bit more
detailed with it but goblin is gonna be
a creature that has ten health it's got
two strengths so these values will get
loaded when it's created as an entity
and strength is some value that our
engine needs to apply to anything that
it decides to attack right you can do
the same thing with defense you could
create arbitrary things it's got a
goblin texture so that's the sprite
we've defined some animations here which
you've already seen how to instantiate
those in our game engine maybe it starts
off with a club weapon and you could
also reference other sort of Lua files
that have these definitions if you have
maybe a weapons deaths file you could
index it into weapons deaths club and
then that club item will maybe have a
bunch of its own characteristics that
when your game engine is loading this
goblin def it loads in the club def as
well and instantiates a bunch of
qualities onto that entity or that item
that then have behavior relevant to your
game engine aggressive is true so if
something's a dot you know entity dot
aggressive then maybe it's a I will seek
out the player right and you can set
that to false so now you can
differentiate between entities that
chase the player and entities that are
sort of docile and just do their own
random thing sleeps at night maybe your
game has a day/night cycle maybe some
entities stay awake and some go into a
sleep state right so it'll look and say
ok it's nighttime does the entity dot
sleeps at night if it does okay then
entity change state sleep right and then
during the day fade when the day happens
you'll do the same thing in Reverse
you'll say if that entity that sleeps at
night then you say entity not awake is
true or whatever it is change state
awake or idle or walking
and then flammable maybe you have
weapons that shoot damage or shoot fire
or maybe you have torches that shoot
fire or some maybe you're in a level
that's like lava and you know if you get
touched the one of the tiles it has a
flammable effect and if it's flammable
you may be your status equals flammable
you take damage over time and you change
your animation maybe you'd get tinted
red or something like that but thinking
about all these different possibilities
and like what your engine is capable of
you can create pretty much arbitrarily
complex data structures and entities and
items and whatever you want in your game
without having to create a goblin class
or a skeleton class or a arbitrarily
complex creature class you just compose
your creature with a tributo
model it's behavior that way composition
over inheritance which we talked about
last week it's very valuable in game
design and that's what unities game
engine sort of approaches because entity
is a purely entity component system
whereby entities are modeled as
collections of components that each do
something and we can sort of almost
think of these as components - I'll be
at a much simpler sort of representation
does anybody have questions as to this
or like why it's useful or anything like
that okay
so the last thing I wanted to talk about
today and I saw I think one or two
students were mentioning how they wish
they knew or wish we talked about a
little bit more how programming was done
back in the day so I'm not an expert
necessarily in sort of programming you
know 6502 assembly which is what the NES
is written in there are a lot of people
that are very good at it
but there's a few links here so in the
slides if you wanted to look at the
slides on the website homebrew is
actually quite a popular thing amongst
certain communities online and what it
is is essentially getting compilers that
will compile source code for some
arbitrary processor or you know
development environment from some
arbitrary computer system like the NES
which was a 8-bit microprocessor based
machine with its own set of interesting
hardware it allows you to compile the
assembly for that and actually run it
via a pro
I'm called an emulator and an emulator
just allows you to run ROM images or you
know just arbitrary data that maps to
the machine instructions of some system
that the emulator has emulated by a
virtual machine and so if you wanted to
look at a look into it a little bit more
in detail the there's a couple links
here so NES tab wiki's got a bunch of
great links there's a programming guide
that kind of goes over the basics of how
to do some 6502 assembly as well as with
the nes and its particular hardware and
then the compiler that most people use
for this is called CC 65 which is a 6502
assembly compiler and so this is an
example of some source code it's a
little bit tough to read but I can zoom
it I don't think but the gist of it is
you have a lot of interact I should
probably pull it up online let me try
SuperMario disassembly so go here this
is on github so somebody decompiled
basically our disassembled rather take
took the bytes that represent all the
machine code and the ROM image of Super
Mario Brothers and then just converted
it back to assembly language and then
added comments to it because I won't go
into too much detail about what assembly
is and how it works but essentially it's
just a layer directly above machine code
where key words map to essentially what
our bytes in memory that are actually
program instructions and that influence
the behavior of your CPU such that you
get programs and that's what C is
layered on top of and every language
thereof there thereafter so if i zoom in
here see if I can be a little slow but
it's letting me
so here we can see somebody's I think
it's lagging because the file is just so
large it's like 14,000 lines of code
because it's this thing about assembly
is assembly it's very very long because
there are so many and you need to have
as just like really slowly zooming and
infinitely there are just so many steps
you need to do in order to achieve the
same thing that you get in a high-level
language like C or or even languages
higher than that taking a lot of things
for granted especially things like you
know loading registers so every CPUs got
a series of registers that can store
values and then the CPU has logic that
knows that you can basically say okay if
the value in register a is greater than
or equal to some value then branch to
this sequence of the assembly code and
you often will have to do things like
and/or operations on byte level you know
I just on bytes like right here we can
see we're anding the value 3 on whatever
is in register a like I said not don't
intend to get too much into what
assembly is but for those curious as to
how games were implemented in the 80s
and even the early 90s it was all in
assembly language because assembly
language is you're literally programming
the the CPU of whatever machine you're
trying to program and that's how you get
as much efficiency as possible if you
know you're computing environment you
know what your CPU is capable of the
thing about compiling a language like C
or C++ or Java which is even higher of
an abstraction than those is you're
allowing sort of algorithms to do the
work for you you're allowing algorithms
to take your source code and turn it
into this basically well a layer lower
than this effectively this is an
intermediary level that it does generate
but suffice to say in the 80s and 90s C
compilers were not as good as humans
were in creating games especially to do
a lot of the tricky things that they
needed to do in order to get them
working efficiently on processors that
were at the time one two three megahertz
in speed which now we have like three
gigahertz
no big deal but that is effectively
that's that's sort of a window into what
it was like developing games in the 80s
and 90s and then in the 90s with like
things like the n64 PlayStation 1 going
on to PlayStation 2 and so forth it was
typically done in a language like C or
C++ sometimes with some variants certain
consoles like the ps3 has a notoriously
difficult graphics processor to program
so a lot of ps3 teams needed to program
in assembly even you know at the time
which was two thousand seven thousand
nine but that's in a nutshell what it's
like programming the 6502 so if you want
those things those links up above it's a
pretty enlightening experience actually
digging into that sort of thing and
trying to make sense of what the
assembly does it's quite difficult and
quite it's quite burdensome because of
how long these programs are and just how
minut each individual instruction is
like just checking just loading a value
into a register just to you know do a
loop often will just be iteratively
loading a value into a register and then
like performing some operation or
calculation off of that and then
branching to some other loop of code a
lot of that can be condensed into like
just a couple lines of C or even fewer
lines of lua so a lot more of a burden
but there is insight definitely some
insight into digging a little deeper and
sort of looking there so once again
those are the links on the NES dev wiki
wiki to any estep comm if you're
interested in looking at that in
assignment 5 you will like you did an
assignment for you can create a game
object that's consumable and feel free
to use code from assignment 4 to do this
one like you define your on consume
function if you're going to adopt the
same model as the last assignment then
any ideas that's what we need to do
probably just add you know the opposite
of damage the entity right we want to
add heart so we want to add HP to it and
you'll see in the distro that health is
modeled as an even number because every
one digit is half a heart yeah you can't
and it'll that will effectively be the
same thing too so the second part is
including pots so there are pots in the
spritesheet so they should these should
be solid so when the player interacts
with them he should be bumped out of
where he was allowed the player to lift
them so there's an animation in the
sprite sheet that will actually allow
that shows the player lifting up the pot
so it probably need a new state player
lift pot state wok with pot state
whatever you want to define it as but
you'll need basically to have those two
in order to get this to work what's one
thing that we'll need to do in order for
the player to lift the pot any ideas
besides the rendering aspect of it when
the player walks around for example what
needs to happen if he's holding the pot
you could make him slower yeah that's
possible that's not it's not required
for the assignment more fundamental than
that the pot needs to track the players
location right it needs to be relative
to the players location so keep the pot
probably above the player to some by
some amount I won't be too picky as to
how you implement that but the pot needs
to track the player which is this next
point actually and their walking
animations like I said should change
while they're carrying it allow the
player lastly to throw the pot so when
you throw the pot basically turn the pot
into a projectile if it hits one of the
walls break it you can either just
de-spawn it instantly or have some
animation it's up to you but just if it
hits a wall de-spawn it trigger - maybe
just trigger it - some values false
render is false whatever you want to do
if it hits an enemy it should damage the
enemy by one just like we've seen
already and if it travels farther than
four tiles in addition to also hitting
one of the walls then destroy it too so
those are the main components as for
assignment 5 and the ways that which you
achieve most of it's fairly flexible but
yeah that's the same at fire or lecture
5 Legend of Zelda so thanks for coming
we'll see you next time